okay let's go
let's get back in the ring charlie
huertas
from the philippines 1580. let's play
the sicilian defense
and he plays the aleppin citilion named
after simone alepan
i'll talk about him later what is the
purpose of the alpine city and the
purpose is to control the center with d4
we need to preempt white from going
before we don't want to let him
control the entire center how can we do
that how can we
preempt white from controlling the set
how can we do it first
what can we do yeah we can go e5 that's
fine
but e5 if you guys may notice weakens
the d5 square
and that kind of i don't want to create
a big weakness on a central square like
that let's go d5
and it is true okay he goes e5
again he wants to play d4
so we're gonna play d4 ourselves to stop
him from doing that
our pawn is sort of wedged here it's
stopping him from naturally controlling
the center
we've got a nice position i'll talk
about this opening a little bit later
bishop b5 we already kind of know how to
respond to this type of move what should
we do
how should we deal with the fact of this
pin
being kind of annoying again not all of
our pieces always need to be
conquering you know the greek or the
okay d3 is a very typical mistake
i need somebody i'm not going to give
you any hints black to play and win
how do i see this two things
number one undefended pieces loose
pieces drop off number two
as soon as a move is made in front of
the king even tangentially
you must look at the diagonals that have
been opened
and consider whether you cannot put a
piece on those diagonals
when a a5 wins a piece and this
basically wins the game because
knight c3 we take remember we have a
pawn on d4 that's why we put it there
right it's all good no but normally
you'd be right zaizi and he's
fuming right now i'm telling you
boom we're also attacking three
different pawns let's take one of them
let's take
oh we should have taken b2 because we
would have probably also won the rook
uh but i i was just too attracted by the
juicy central pawn on d3
okay now what do i always tell you guys
when we win a lot of material
when we win a lot of material what do
you not want to forget to do
what do you not want to forget to do
no not trade develop
develop your pieces when you want
material do not forget about that
trading and i talked about this at the
very beginning of the speed run
it's good in general trading is good
when you're up material but
two things to point out it's not the
only way to convert
a material advantage you can also use
your material to attack i call this sort
of method one
and the other thing is that people get
in a lot of trouble by the way just
defending the pawn
people get in a lot of trouble when you
go out of your way to trade pieces
you don't want to [ __ ] your entire
position solely for the purpose of
trading one pair of pieces if a trade
falls in your lap as as
these trades are here sure go ahead and
trade a bunch of pieces fine
but but not if you have to [ __ ] your
position somehow
just for the sake of one trade so here
for example the trades are literally
falling in our lap
he's offering us to take the bishop
queen to c3 basically forces the queen
trade
in fact ladies and gentlemen we have
kind of a nice move here
how do we get this queen out of d6 we
can basically trap it we can go queen c5
but let's look for something even better
boom knight f5 get back to b4 forcing
the trade
we win the game okay
all right queen before we take it
and now the same rules remain in the end
game we don't want to forget to
consolidate do we need this one we don't
need the spot
we don't need the spawn let's deploy our
bishop to the most
active square and what should we do now
in the interest of things that i
explained can somebody tell me a good
move in this position
we can again if a trade falls in your
lap
yeah and everybody's suggesting good
moves king e7 is great increasing the
coordination between the pieces
castling is not as good in the end game
because there's no need to castle we can
do the same thing
as we would when we castle by putting
our king on e7 which is closer to the
center now we got to be very careful
bishop b7 would run into a nasty little
check on c7 how do we circumvent that
we can just drop it to d7 right we force
the rook trade
the game is over okay
infiltrating
infiltrating we're going to just start
picking off his pawns how do we convert
this position
we identify the area where we can create
a pass pawn
and then we create one either by taking
a bunch of our opponent's pawns or
by pushing our pawns and just creating a
password
i this there's no rocket science here
right i'm literally doing as i say
i'm going to create a pass pawn and i'm
going to use my extra material the extra
bishop
to force white's rook away he's probably
gonna go rook b3
yep so no problem let's defend the pawn
of the rock now where should we put our
bishop to dislodge the rook from b3
yeah just let's go here bishop c6 bishop
d5
b3 the fact of the matter is we have so
much extra material
that we can use it to continually get
this rook out of
its blockading post that's just how you
usually win these types of positions not
the only way
boom b2 is very formulaic then bishop b4
it's the same thing repeated again and
again until
his rook has to permanently move away or
give itself up for the plot
and then we're going to have a rook
extra
okay identify a passport yeah well
sometimes you
sometimes you see a specific pass pawn
that you can create
sometimes you see the general area of
the board where a passpond can be
created but you don't know exactly which
pass pawn it's going to be
okay
goodbye that's over yeah this is not the
only way to convert this again
i want to make it very clear that when
i'm winning like this there's a
million possible moves on every move uh
there isn't just one way of doing this
i'm just trying to show the most sort of
play it by the rules by the book way of
converting
same thing by the way we're just going
to create a pass pawn we're going to
push it
even though i'm up a million pieces we
could literally we don't have to push
any of our pawns i can move my king up
and checkmate him
but the easiest is just going to be to
push the pawn
forget don't forget about not
stalemating that's why and there we go
1600 ladies and gentlemen
and uh this is a great place to stop but
let's take a quick look at the game
first
okay so the elephant sicilian is named
after jimon alopin who was a lithuanian
chess master from i believe the early
20th century
uh and who was the first to play the
elephant thank you trash pandaman for
the sub
let's take some bets
who thinks that that aleppin
shimon alepan was the first person to
play the alpine
let's get a yay who thinks that alpine
was the first person to play an alpine
no he was not the first person to play
an elephant he was
the fourth person sorry the fifth person
to play the elephant but he was one of
the earliest proponents of it
the first person to play the alpine was
a
in in recorded modern recorded history
was a guy named william popert
in london in 1841 he played it against
howard staunton one of the strongest
players of the 19th century and
beat him with the alpine then it was
played in 19 in 1842 by
john william shulton another very strong
english player
but got crushed and
only in 1898 was it played by alepan
himself
so as i've made clear before some of
these openings are named after people
but that doesn't mean those people were
the first people to play them sometimes
they never even played the opening named
after them as in the case of the
philidor
the philidor is named after philidor but
he never actually played it
i think he just talked about it in his
book but it's kind of interesting how
this kind of chess naming stuff works
the damiano is often named after damiano
this is a horrible move
and i've shared this story many times
damiano
a 17th century chess master wrote one of
the first books
ever on chess and
he refuted the damiana but we don't call
it damiano's reputation like who is this
dummy damiano
he was the one who actually said it was
bad uh and
and yet we think it was the city of
damiano who wanted to play f6 so it's
just interesting how
this kind of stuff works but we played
d5 and he played a weird move e5
um e takes d5 is the main move
now what is the what is the
reason why uh this is better than a
scandi well if you look very carefully
at this position you compare it to a
scandi
who can tell me what the main difference
is uh with the insertion of these moves
like
wha what move does yeah knight c3 is not
possible and as you guys know
that's often one of the key indicators
for whether a queen is safe in the
center
can he develop the knight and attack the
queen simultaneously
and here the answer is no i played the
alpine myself as my main opening for
many years
there is a theoretical line that goes
like this and this is a very interesting
opening i mean it's it's not clear who's
better
uh it's a very rich rich position which
i will not go into right now
but um this is you know the movie five
he wants to transpose into some sort of
a french but we stopped him from doing
that right we
went we wedged the pawn through to d4
and then his key mistake was d3
uh which which allows of course this
fork against his bishop
what should he have done if he castled
we actually have another nice tactic in
this position
oh but there's some beautiful counter
tactics
the bishop on b5 what can you tell me
about it i'm defended remember what i
said about pins
they go both ways either side can
exploit
a pin it's like a two-sided coin how can
we exploit the bishop on b5
we can do knight takes e5 this is a very
typical idea
it's a bit you're like did you just say
it's a very typical idea have you
personally daniel of you personally
applied this idea in one of your games
if you personally applied what do you
guys think yes i have in fact i can show
you the very game
in which uh this position this type of
tactical this is a very very typical
tactic
uh it truly is and um i'm stalling
because i'm loading up the game
and trying to do it as fast as possible
i just managed to do it
and uh there we go
okay so i had a game in 2010
where something very similar happened i
was playing an im
and my opponent played bishop g5 in this
position
the bishop here isn't strictly speaking
undefended it is protected by the queen
but if you look at this very carefully
i've got two pieces that are sort of
x-raying that bishop and so knight takes
d5 happens
the same knight that captures the pawn
is guarding the bishop which is very
important because
if i could not take back with the knight
here i would lose the knight
and uh here you could just take with a
knight and i'm up a pawn
and if he takes on d5 then obviously
i play bishop takes g5 and i'm up a pawn
so
very similar tactical idea so this is
quite typical
but the problem here is if you calculate
a little bit further
what you'll see is that after knight
takes e5 bishop takes b5
black is very poorly i mean i'm not
developed what
move and white is a very nasty move here
which wins the game for white
again the bishop is undefended
square on f7 you have to pay attention
to this boom
fork attacking the bishop and attacking
f7
this shows the importance of always
having to calculate as far as possible
a lot of people are falling in love with
knight f7 this would be worse
remember the piece of advice i shared
earlier if you have a two move sequence
one move two moves you want to consider
both move orders because sometimes you
only consider one move order
you forget that by making the second
move first
you greatly increase the effectiveness
of that operation so queen b3
would actually win the game it would win
the bishop or it would deliver checkmate
and so uh if he had castled we probably
should have gone e6 and just continued
our development
okay uh the idea behind knight f7 is a z
could be either
queen h5 or queen b3 i think both moves
are quite equivalent
you could win the bishop this way or you
could win the bishop this way but the
net result of it is the same the king is
out in the open black is worse
but it's a question of how much worse
here black is completely lost
so this is this is crushing and that's
just
part of why chess is a cruel game you
know sometimes you can see a lot more
than your opponent
our opponent may have even missed the
move knight takes e5
but this kind of tactic falls into his
lap that's one of the things that always
concerns me when i'm playing quite
you know weaker players is i might see a
lot more than them
but i'm gonna have to choose a path at
some point and a tactic like this could
be low-hanging fruit so
you know that's part of the equation um
okay uh so so that's basically how that
happened and after we won the piece
the rest was very simple we should have
taken b2 of course i forgot that the
spawn was on d4 usually
bishop c3 is possible but here it's not
and uh
his only way to save the rook is to give
up the knight and that gives up a second
piece
uh and like that time i got my queen
trapped exactly that's a great example
of that so here we just
traded all the pieces defended what
needed to be defended forcing the queen
trade giving up the pond to trade more
pieces
bringing the bishop to beast to d7 not
b7 allowing this
and uh identifying the area of the board
where we can create a pass pawn
creating a pass pawn using our extra
piece to dislodge the rook
cooperating rook and bishop again create
a pass
pawn push it and he resigns simple
textbook play it by the rules can be
very effective
yeah let's go okay so let's go e4
as we have been customarily doing okay
knight c6 that's the nimzovich defense
uh d4 is possible here another good move
is knight f3
um and yeah so he goes d5 so this is
like a souped-up version of the skandy
our response is no different than it
would be in the scandy so what should
white do here
how how do we usually play in this candy
like what what are the next two moves
actually
just knight c3 is correct and then d4
okay queen h5 yeah this is um
it's actually kind of a dangerous system
okay so d4
yeah this is what aquila plays by the
way one of my close friends in mods
and uh this actually is an opening that
we we have to respond very accurately to
now um black's idea is is to very
quickly pile up on the
d4 pawn okay and for that reason he's
putting all
of he's putting all his eggs in one
basket he's gonna castle and he's gonna
basically have the equivalent of four
pieces
either directly or indirectly attacking
the d4 pawn so the correct move in this
position
is to immediately go after the knight on
c6 this is just theoretical knowledge
and i will explain this properly after
the game but it's not an intuitive move
because it allows uh bishop takes f3
which kind of cripples the pawn
structure
but that's okay and i'll show you guys
why uh d5 is the tempting move here but
he castles
and the rook then pins the queen i'll
show this in detail after the game
and let me remember yeah and now the
move is queen to e2
and a bishop yeah again i this is a bit
theoretical so uh delving into the
details would require me to move the
pieces around
okay bishop b4 now we can sort of play
based on our understanding
he pins the other knight and this guy
really goes after me
and uh you know we need to defend
first and foremost against against this
pin
and so we're going to do that by going
bishop to d2 just preventing
taking the sting out of this pin
unpinning ourselves
and um his the correct move for black
would be knight gd yeah he's very good
this guy has played the opening
extremely well
um and i should know this a little bit
better this line
let me think
yeah so let's chase the bishop away
first of all now let's let's make this
bishop decide what it wants to do
and it's good to ask your opponent
questions in this regard you know
like forcing your opponent to yeah let's
let's chase the bishop away entirely
and now the spawn is once again under
some pressure so we're going to get this
bishop out to e3
to protect that pawn to give it some
support
and um yeah no i i definitely we didn't
play this particularly well
well d4 is not hanging because remember
that we're pinning the knight but he
should castle here
yeah and he's he's in very good shape in
this position we're going to go rook d1
to try to defend upon he's going to go
rook d8
no knight f5 is probably okay this is
inaccurate
and the reason this is inaccurate is
because he leaves a particular piece
unattended which piece does he leave
unattended what can we take here
to lessen the the immediate pressure on
the pawn yeah we can take the knight
and we also kind of double his pawns
which i should have done much earlier
and and now we need to discharge well
we need to solve the problem of the
spawn okay this pawn is bothering the
hell out of me
and the way to solve the problem of a
weak pawn first and foremost is to ask
yourself can i defend it with another
pawn
and um well the answer is yes you can
defend it with a c
pawn to defend it with a c pawn you have
to move this knight now where should we
move this knight well we should move it
to a
civilized square square where it's also
doing something let's move it toward the
center with knight to e4
and again this is
a complicated position white is
certainly not better here
but um these are the kinds of positions
where usually like 1600s really struggle
yeah and that's a big mistake knight
takes c4 is a very big mistake and
that's a very typical mistake from
from someone of his rating range which
i'll explain afterward
why is it a mistake because this knight
on f5 that he had is actually a super
strong piece and what he allows us to do
is is solve the problem of the pawn
right we take with the pawn and now look
at his bishop it's
biting at granite we didn't even need to
play c3
and he's left with bishops he doesn't
have a knight and a knight would be a
great kind of screwdriver type of piece
here
and now he he tries to attack us but
i've got enough beef here on the king's
side
in in the form of both knights he's also
weak in the e5 square later
maybe i could stick a knight there
although most likely he's going to take
this night with his bishop
and uh well we can continue our
development by castling we can finally
castle our king
f4 would be a good move here he's yeah
he's
this guy is vastly underrated
and now we still have to play c3 because
he's eliminated the defender of
of the d4 pawn so we have to reinforce
it again he's probably going to go here
now the reason that i still like white's
position here
is because this bishop on b6 is terrible
and it's buried it's completely buried
it can't get out of the game
the only way that it can get out of the
game is if black
orchestrates some sort of dastardly
scheme
with e5 so why does e5
work e5 may work because the bishop is
exerting this pin
over the case so what can we do to kind
of prevent it to prevent e5 to take the
sting out of it what can we do
well we could go c4 but yeah c4 but that
would weaken the d4 square let's just
get
let's just stick a queen there now
there's a beautiful variation i have to
show you guys
let me not forget we could have moved
our king to h1
uh and that's the sort of typical
prophylactic mode but then there's a
beautiful variation
that i think would have actually landed
that in quite a bit of trouble okay so
he trades on f3
there's a lot to unpack in this game
it's a very instructive game
uh and and we have a lot of analyzing to
do so i'm sorry for not explaining
some of the key things here but trust me
i'll go over them after the game
and now he's worse he's made another
very instructive mistake
he's given up his strongest pair of
pieces which were exerting pressure on
our position
and in his logic he's he's weakened our
king side pawn structure but this is
nothing that we can't deal with
maybe we can just bring our king up and
the king is nicely defending both
weaknesses
and he's left with a terrible bishop
that's never going to enter the game
because he can't enter it backwards and
he can't enter it forwards the pawns are
limiting it
so now what we have to do is make sure
that that black doesn't get anywhere so
let's go rook to d2 to stop
the queen penetration to c2 and
r5 is a nice move we can't take the rook
because of the pin but we can just drop
the queen back to e4
we're starting to attack his weaknesses
finally
he attacks our rook but he blunders the
pawn on e6 and his position has started
to crumble
his position has started to crumble he's
got to go rook f7 otherwise
we either take the rook now we can move
our work out of the way
and uh yeah this bishop is is what's
gonna kill him uh he's basically playing
down a piece
and he's doing a great job of it and you
know what the most instructive thing to
do here is well actually we can just
take the pawn
we could have just traded all of the
pieces because he would have been
literally left with
uh this bishop that is that is
completely useless but as it stands
we can win another pawn and he's
probably gonna get his queen out and
miss queen a8 which is checkmate nope
yeah this guy is is just flat out good
um
not an easy win at all and uh but we're
gonna take another one now he he
nobly tries to involve his bishop the
problem is by the time he activates his
bishop the earth will have turned into a
supernova and disappeared into the
universe
i mean he's losing all of his pawns
we're gonna give him a nice little check
to dislodge the king so that we can take
g7 as well
and yeah goodbye and this is just
checkmate
i mean well we're winning all of his
pieces and yeah the bishop
bishop is now active congratulations but
i think he's uh
and he watch him go bishop c7 that'll be
hilarious he finally activates his
bishop
but he has no pieces left i think he's
gonna resign
oh planets don't turn into a supernova
that's funny
okay well it just takes an h4
i don't know why he's not resigning oh
there we go here it comes
here it comes here it comes
all right get and now it's going to give
itself up for the yep
okay i have no idea where this man is
playing
just none zero let me just get our king
up
just don't stalemate the guy
hmm
okay he wants stalemate but he's not
gonna get it
one order of stalemate coming up okay
that was a really rich game actually
uh so and i know that to some people it
can be annoying that we spend a long
time on the games and stuff but
that's my job here again i i need to if
there's a particularly instructive game
i owe it to everybody to really explain
everything as best i can
because that's why we're doing the speed
run uh and
if so okay so queen h5 right
uh bishop so i think that okay i think
my mistake actually
i'm not actually sure where my mistake
was because i'm pretty sure this is the
theoretical move
now a couple of things in this position
uh the move d5 is extremely tempting
because it looks active you're attacking
the knight but but the problem is that
he castles
and okay in a certain sense we've bitten
off more than we can chew because well
you can't take the knight because you
lose the queen
and that might not seem like a problem
right okay big deal
i can just develop my bishop but but
look at what happens he plays e6
and and white does not have the the
manpower
necessary to just defend this pawn i
mean you just lose the central pawn
because of this incredibly nasty pin
the plaque is exerting on the queen and
um
you know and you're just going to end up
upon down for no compensation
that's what makes this line very
dangerous and actually a good weapon for
people in this writing range
now some other people were like okay i
get it uh i get why not d5 but why
why are you not why are you not cutting
the effectiveness of this pin
well the problem here is very similar
black castles right
and what's going on here look at this
pawn on d4 very carefully
how can black apply the most pressure to
this pawn with this next move
how can this is the reason why i didn't
play like this this very nasty little
move
uh that that really puts this pawn under
the microscope
and well look at that i mean look at how
much pressure there is
on all aspects of white's position here
and if you go d5 now again black doesn't
need to move his knight from c6
and if white tries to unpin himself by
moving the queen well again you lose the
pawn
so you know you're damned if you do and
damned if you don't
and this is a very nasty position uh so
does this make sense to everybody
and and i want i want this to make sense
because it's important to understand
how the mechanism of this opening
so that's why i played bishop b5 because
preemptively
i'm trying to take this knight out of
commission for two reasons first of all
i'm discouraging him from castling
why because he's gonna have to deal with
a ruined pawn structure where his king
is and that's nobody likes that
uh and the second thing is that
literally i mean if i take his knight
then he's got one less piece attacking
d4
but whoops sorry but uh somehow i
mistimed
the bishop takes c6 move and
uh probably what i should have done is
is just taken and developed my bishop
and played this normally
but i tried to be fancy i played queenie
too uh and the idea behind this move is
to
preemptively unpin myself so i'm
preemptively
counteracting the effectiveness of him
putting a rook onto it that's no longer
going to pin the queen that used to be
on d1
and also i'm uh potentially angling for
one of these squares to apply more
pressure on the knight
but he goes bishop before pinning me the
other way
uh and somehow like white just doesn't
have again the resources necessary to to
defend
against all of these criss-crossing pins
so can you explain why the ruined pawns
on the king side aren't a big deal yeah
exactly
so i should yeah we should take the
knight now um but but i tried to delay
this and honestly i missed 97.
i i forgot that he can get his knight
into the game and
simultaneously support his other knight
so that if we take
uh that the effectiveness of that is
completely nullified because now one
knight has replaced the other
um and and i mistimed bishop takes c6
now a couple of people are wondering
okay
i get it why am i not afraid of bishop
takes f3
why is this pawn structure not
to be feared and there is two things
first of all i've often talked about how
pawn structure is not the most important
factor for evaluating the position
and let me make one very important
clarification
i mentioned earlier that black's pawn
structure being ruined near black's king
is disastrous
why is that the case and
why do we not care as much about the
pawn structure on white scent
so i introduced an analogy imagine two
houses houses are both
in a very bad state of repair olds and
they're collapsing
but in one one house is abandoned and
the houses
next door are also abandoned and it's a
matter of time before the house
collapses and eventually the house does
collapse and it causes damage to the
surrounding streets and surrounding
houses
and that's not good uh but
in the other house there's like a huge
family that lives there
and if the house collapses it causes
death and it's a tightly packed
community and it impacts the houses next
door and the people there are impacted
so
pawn structure is completely relative to
what's going on
on that side of the board black's king
queenside pawn structure is like that
house where people live
uh and because it's ruined it's a lot
easier to access
black's king but if you look at white
spawn structure why can't just castle
queenside
why can decide to live on the other side
of the board
and the worst thing that's possibly
going to happen
in regards to this pawn structure is
that
uh well black might win one pawn big
freaking whoop he's gonna win one pawn
okay that's not the end of the world
uh sometimes it is but not in this
specific instance
okay what is the worst thing that could
happen for black
checkmate black could get checkmated in
like two moves
okay so when you were evaluating pawn
structure
you have to understand two main things
pawn strike pawn structure tends to be
a particularly important phenomenon
under two conditions
first is that there is a king next to
the pawn structure that has been
impacted
number two is that you're close to an
end game in pawn
end games pawn structure is crucial
because it determines which side has the
easier time
creating a past one right uh and
but but in a normal middle game like a
dub pair of double pawns is just
not nothing to fret over in most cases
that doesn't mean it's not important
that doesn't mean it doesn't need to be
factored in but hopefully this makes
some sense and that's
basically the reason why we're not
afraid of bishop f3
okay even if we didn't get a chance to
take on c6
i wouldn't really mind black taking on
f3 hopefully that makes sense
okay that was a little out there but um
you know what what ended up happening is
that we didn't get a chance to take his
knight
and so he was able to sort of extend the
pressure on this pawn
uh without us being able to lessen it by
taking the night it was a whole idea of
bishop e5
and knight f5 was the first inaccuracy
because he allowed us now to take the
knight and and
ruin his pawn structure and bury his
bishop which is a lot more important by
the way
than his pawn structure being ruined
again it's not the pawn structure itself
that's important here it's the fact that
it buries his bishop in the self-made
prison
uh and what should he have done how
should he have exerted pressure on the
spawn instead
of knight five
well e5 would be e5 would be like
throwing out the baby with a bathwater
maybe you were you're allowing te but um
or d5 but rookie d8 and then maybe
double rooks right it's not rocket
science and
then at the right moment you take on f3
and you do that because you win the pawn
so it's as simple as that now the second
mistake
if you're a 1600 listen up because this
is in my opinion i don't i don't mean to
sound condescending i true i'm
passionate about getting this out there
because i think it could help people
i mean at any level and this is the
concept of
prematurely you know okay how should i
say this
without people interpreting this the
wrong way but
by releasing the tension or prematurely
trading pieces you can call it a million
different things but it's this tendency
to go for a
clarified position or a forced line
rather than keeping the tension on the
board
okay and you see this all the time
like you have a trade that could be made
to clarify the position and people just
do it
but every single trade has to be
evaluated
very very carefully and a trade
like this one has the capacity to change
the course of the game completely it's
it's not just oh i take a bishop or a
knight whatever
okay this could completely derail the
progress that black has been making and
it does
because what it what this move does is
it it
absolves me of the need to defend the d4
pawn
black's knight was basically the only
piece that could exert
serious pressure on my position and in
fact the ironic thing is
what would be black's correct move here
and i say ironic because
it's actually not to take the bishop but
to do something useful with the knight
what did he have done
he could have redirected the the
pressure onto my knight
and if i allow knight takes f3 my
position collapses so
knight g3 was what i plan to do but
white is hanging by a thread here you
can take this pawn
and i'm attacking his queen so if he
takes my knight
you get a mass liquidation and i'm upon
down here but again his bishop is buried
so
that's what's important but i realize
now that that he's got queen h3
and now he's really getting to my king
and guess what piece is at the middle of
all of this it's the knight
so uh so for that reason
knight takes e3 was actually a very very
uh disastrous mistake and
he's still doing okay here uh but
without this bishop
his position is is very very very
difficult and uh we won
sim okay so here we stop we stop him
from going e5 and exploiting the pin by
the way the beautiful line
you guys ready for a jaw dropping
idea if we go king h1 what i didn't like
is that he can go e5
anyway and we you could look at this and
say wait isn't that the entire reason
that we went king h1 so that we could
take the pawn
well yes but watch this now he takes the
knight
now it turns out that we can take with a
pawn but the natural recapture would be
rook takes f3
could somebody find black's idea here
okay this is not like
crazy but it's kind of nice
boom goes the dynamite and guess what
piece is behind it all bishop on b6
which has been
activated and rook h4 checkmate that's i
think there's a name for this it's like
the
it's not the arabian made it's not
anastasia's made it's some
version of the two and that's what i
didn't want to allow
so that's why we simply put a piece on
the e5 square blockading that square
entirely
and and the rest was very simple the
rest was a matter of consolidating
defending our weaknesses stopping the
queen from
infiltrating and then eventually picking
up the pieces that
start to crumble because black did not
hold everything together because he's
playing down a piece
um okay so that's basically how we won
so the key moment in the game really was
in the beginning me not taking on c6
and delaying that for too long allowing
97
and then him going knight of five
big well not a big mistake but knight
takes e3 and this was the big mistake
and it doesn't you can look at this game
quickly and you can gloss over this
moment entirely because it looks like a
completely innocuous trait but
positionally speaking it's
it's a disaster um are you playing the
best moves which you would actually play
in a game for the most part yes i'm
actually playing full strength
i'm making some decisions uh to simplify
the game but not many
so basically i'm playing my normal
strength and that's an ambitious
you know project i'm trying to explain
my moves but i'm not really modifying my
play style
you